[Applause]
chinese fighter jets carried out
simulated attacks as they flew near
taiwan's airspace
warships sailed close to the island's
military bases in major ports
and long-range rockets flew in the
direction of the self-ruled democracy
all this was part of war games following
house speaker nancy pelosi's visit to
taipei
to understand what china's army is doing
military analysts have been looking at
footage from state media and mapping the
locations where the drills have taken
place
beijing sees taiwan as part of its own
territory and with these military drills
it's showing how it would seek to
isolate the island in the event of a
conflict
these are six zones where the chinese
people's liberation army has been
holding its exercises in recent days
china is appears to be
practicing
its ability to enforce a blockade in
taiwan by putting its ships and planes
basically in a big circle around taiwan
during the drills china showed that
different branches of its army can work
in sync china is clearly trying to show
that it can operate in various regions
around taiwan it can coordinate that
large military across the seas and the
air and with its missiles and its
intelligence gathering its communication
its reconnaissance
but the drills also showed that
beijing's military has limitations
military analysts say that china appears
to lack the assets to impose a total
blockade of the island so instead it
seems to be preparing for a sort of
quarantine around taiwan a mini blockade
of taiwan cutting off aspects of its
connections with the rest of the world
allowing taiwan to import food but not
allowing it to bring in other materials
for instance oil looking closer at where
some of the zones were set up shows how
china could choke off the island this
zone located north of taiwan is just
some 30 miles away from taipei which is
home to the island's busiest
international airport and this southwest
zone is near taiwan's most important
commercial port
and then there's the taiwan strait one
of the busiest trade routes in the world
the proximity of the action to key
shipping routes in the region triggered
the delays of some commercial flights
and shipments demonstrating the pain
china could also inflict on world
commerce this is a very active area for
shipping connecting korea and japan with
the oil markets of the middle east
connecting the semiconductor industry
with the rest of the world the drills
also took place in parts of japan's
exclusive economic zone an area of the
sea that gives sovereign states the
rights to exploit and control marine
resources japan's defense minister says
some of china's missiles landed there
if there is a chinese
live fire exercise in those seas
commercial ships will be deterred and
that will certainly collapse uh trade in
that area
the chinese military said it would
continue the drills around taiwan beyond
the initially announced four days so as
tensions continue to mount the question
is whether these exercises would
escalate larger military activity in the
region any sustained
effort like we've seen with these
exercises is clearly going to result in
more military activity by the us
possibly by japan and and other powers
in the region